Rock Solid is how China's top Diplomat
described the relationship between
Beijing and Moscow in his meeting with
the Russian president Wang Yi said the
ties between the two nations were not
directed against anyone but won't accept
pressure from any country as well
we have always maintained a strategic
focus and adhered to the general
direction of building a multi-polar
world resolutely opposed in the
unilateral and hegemonic actions and
safeguarded our respective sovereignty
security and development interests a day
after the Russian and American
Presidents made speeches ahead of the
anniversary of the war with Ukraine
Vladimir Putin told China their ties
extend beyond diplomacy
we cooperate in many areas in the
humanitarian sphere in international
organizations including the United
Nations the security Council of which
we're permanent members brics the
Shanghai cooperation organization and of
course we're waiting for the chairman of
the People's Republic of China to visit
Russia China wants to promote its peace
plan to bring the warring sides in
Ukraine to the negotiating table but
with its deep-rooted cooperation with
Russia it's not widely seen as a neutral
arbiter
China has a number of joint
infrastructure projects with Russia with
most Chinese investment in the resource
Rich far east region Western sanctions
mean China's Imports of Russian oil
natural gas and goods have become more
lucrative
in South Africa Russia and China are
taking part in a three-nation military
exercise
cooperation like that is a cause for
concern for the NATO military Alliance
backing Ukraine
but Beijing has rejected warnings to
refrain from providing lethal military
aid and it's accused the U.S of fueling
the war by sending weapons to Kiev
asbest and sanctions continue to pile on
Russia it's looking East but China has
its largest trading partner President
Vladimir Putin expects bilateral trade
to balloon over 200 billion dollars and
as the war in Ukraine goes on Russia is
poised to build new alliances and Forge
old ones so that it can avoid
International isolation
Moscow